he has bypassed the cabinet office
really with whom he's been in dispute
about what should be handed over now
he's written a letter a second letter
actually within 24 hours to baroness
Hallett who's chairing the covert
inquiry saying I'm sending your inquiry
all unredacted whatsapps that I provided
to the cabinet's office and uh he's uh
said in a letter to uh baroness Hallett
uh commenting really on the government's
decision to go to court he said the
government yesterday decided to take
legal action it was not my decision to
do so while I understand the
government's position I'm not willing to
let my material become a test case for
others when I'm perfectly content for
the inquiry to see it now in relation to
something we've heard about the last
couple of days uh the complaint the
cabinet office made about him only
handing over material from May 22 21
he has pointed out of course that this
he there was a security breach uh his
mobile phone previously uh the number
was leaked and he had to change phones
uh he was advised he said not to reopen
or switch on the phone again while he's
talking to the cabinet's office he says
about doing that and he says to baroness
Hallett I'd like to do the same with um
my any material Me Maybe on an old phone
which I've been previously been told I
can no longer access safely that's what
he was told by security Chiefs he says
and um so he uh Mr Johnson says he's
hoping to send everything the government
is pursuing its inquiry it's legal
battle some top Tories I think it's a
mistake it's ill-advised so Robert
Buckland said today it was a Fool's
errand
it's reported tonight in the I newspaper
that the government is considering a
further legal move to try and restrict
access to all its whatsapps and
notebooks and so on if it loses the
court case but we're a little aware of
that yet
um the government has launched it's
what's called a judicial review but uh
probably a week or two before we hear
the results of that so the row goes on
between the governments and the inquiry
and of course the clash between Mr
Johnson and Mr sunac